لقد فشل في تقسيم الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين ،
لكننا بحاجة إلى أن نكون صادقين
مع الشعب الأمريكي
، فمعركة
الحرية تكلفتها هنا في الوطن ، كما
يشعر الناس بالفعل
بارتفاع أسعار بوتين في المضخة ، وأعتقد
أن الأمريكيين يعرفون مدى أهمية
هذه المعركة  هل
أعتقد أنهم يعرفون أنه بقدر ما هو مؤلم مثل
السعر اليوم ، فإن التكاليف ستكون
أعلى إذا لم نتحرك الآن للتعامل مع
هذا الطاغية
[موسيقى]
الذي يُزعم أننا نطور
أسلحة بيولوجية
يُزعم أننا نستعد لهجوم كيميائي
مما يجعله  أنا قلق حقًا
لأننا اقتنعنا مرارًا وتكرارًا
إذا كنت تريد معرفة خطط روسيا ، انظر
إلى ما تتهمه روسيا للآخرين بأن
ينظروا إلى
نشر مثل هذه الاتهامات في
وسائل الإعلام الروسية يظهر أنهم
هم القادرون على ذلك
، الجيش الروسي الخدمات الخاصة الروسية
ذلك  يظهر أنهم يريدون ذلك ،
لقد فعلوا بالفعل مثل هذه الأشياء في
بلدان أخرى مماثلة
، وأعلنوا
بأنفسهم أنهم نظموا أنفسهم
اشتكوا وسيفعلون ذلك
مرة أخرى ، نحن متهمون بشن هجمات على
روسيا التي يُزعم أنها سلمية
، والآن ما هي هذه
المزاعم بالتحضير لهجمات كيماوية هل
قررت تنفيذ إزالة المواد الكيميائية
من أوكرانيا
باستخدام الأمونيا
باستخدام الفوسفور ، وماذا
أعددت لنا أيضًا؟
هل ستضرب بالأسلحة الكيميائية ،
نحن أشخاص
مناسبون ، أنا رئيس
دولة مناسبة وأمة مناسبة
وأب لطفلين ولم يتم تطوير
أي أسلحة كيميائية أو أي أسلحة دمار شامل
أخرى على أرضي ، يعلم العالم بأسره
أنك تعرف ذلك  وإذا فعلت شيئًا
كهذا ضدنا ،
فستتلقى أشد العقوبات
عليك